Making a good first impression is the key to landing any job.
And that starts with your resume.
Learn how to properly send it out and land that job.
You'll need: a resume and a cover letter, recipient's contact information,...
...several formats of your resume and a follow-up inquiry.
Step 1: Send a cover letter with the resume.
Be sure to tailor both the resume and cover letter to each specific job you're applying for.
Step 2: Find the name of a specific person at the company who you can address your resume to.
This will ensure that it ends up on their desk or in their inbox rather than floating around the office.
Step 3: If it's not clear from the job ad,...
...inquire with the company about which method of sending they prefer:...
...e-mail, fax or mail.
Step 4: Send the resume as a PDF attachment.
There are many different word processors and not all are compatible with each format.
The job posting might note which format is preferred.
Try copying and pasting your resume into the body of the e-mail...
...if you don't know which format to go with.
Step 5: Follow up on the resume with a phone call or e-mail...
...after about a week if you haven't heard anything.
Good luck.
Did you know, the United States Postal Service's first postmaster general was Benjamin Franklin,...
...who was appointed in 1775?